leute was geht ab ios oder max zusammen
mit sp und wir gehen auf den server in
321 also die lage ist die folgende
wiesen heute tagesaktuell heißt wir
haben nicht vorproduziert weil es nicht
geklappt hat
die folge unsere letzte folge ist jetzt
online die leute wissen wo wir sind und
es kann sein dass wir jetzt ab gestoppt
werden aber wir leben das jolo laufen
deswegen jetzt drauf 321 erholt und
einer erkundet das ding da unten ist ein
online-dialog mal auf die lebensalter
erfolg wieder voll wenig leben hier
alles klar
ich komm raus du gehst in die hölle ich
habe nämlich auch gar kein food männer
also uns wirklich was dran gelegen
welches du bist ja noch geschützt weißt
was ich bin nicht mehr geschützt du was
machst du mit dem kurzen gespräch
ich bin immer noch also ich will plan
ist hast du ja schon erklärt wir haben
ja diese höhle gefunden und mir wurde
zugetragen dass das das größte special
in minecraft halten ist und das heißt
wir können damit halt so einiges machen
ich muss man immer nach oben wie ein
bisschen holz holen damit ich weiter
hier mit der spitzhacke durchmarschieren
kann
hast du vielleicht ist nämlich alles von
diesem von diesem metall was wir woraus
man sich ein ziemlich gutes zu machen
kann und damit könnten wir dann halt
unseren anfänglichen nachteil kann man
schon sagen ein bisschen ausbrechen wenn
hier auch erstmal also ich sehe draußen
keine tiere
man kann aber das verhungern bitte
keiner verhungern oder aber ich weiß
nicht und die rabbids habe keinen bock
ihr fleisch zu glauben dass für die
nächste verdienen
also ich eben wie viel essen hast du
noch weil bei mir ist nicht mehr so viel
und die nacht beginnt das ok erstmals
erprobt
besorgte wirklich so viel du kannst weil
ich will also ich hab ich habe noch 26
junge wie kannst du so viel mehr als ich
ich habe jetzt mitteilt und drei schwein
kann mir mal bitte irgendwo ein und
kommt ja ich baue ich seit ewigkeiten
hier nur durch ist es unendlich dunkel
wird es nacht oder wie ja es ist schon
nach es schon ab misst prinz der in acht
aber das ist gut kann ich versprechen
ja ich kann ewig schon vor allem ist es
verdammt dunkles zu mitleid dafür
ich hoffe nur dass ich jetzt ein
wir brauchen wir wirklich nur einen ein-
und dann können wir uns erst gutes zeug
machen
der clou ist nämlich diese zentren
rüstung allerdings nicht wissen wo jack
newton erstmal wirklich das ist
irgendwie ich glaube dass das der das
eisenvorkommen muss irgendwie krass
kümmerlich genervt sein was reduziert
das ist das ist ein dickes problem ein
bisschen
siehst du schon wo ich bin ich mache
hier brighton und strippen und es
passiert nichts ich kann auch nicht
spenden
ich spaziere jetzt in die höhle rein
viermal schon aufgenommen also wir haben
auf jeden fall richtig wichtig sind der
höhle selbst ja auch noch reisende aus
mancher also darunter gehen
ich mache hier gerade aufs tritt man so
ein bisschen weil ich dachte es müsste
was kommt und es ist einfach viel zu
dunkel also ich sehe gar nichts also ein
eisenhammer wir noch im rufen ein eisen
habe ich noch im inventar wie unser ich
habe auch schon was von diesem roten ohr
gefunden dass das rote nochmal hier ist
lava weißt du was das sollte ist
zufällig das rote weiß ich nicht mehr
gibt irgendwie auch einen modus wo man
sich das anzeigen lassen kann wo man
drauf also wer mir auf dem fall ruby
perfekt ich hab noch ein eisen gefunden
dem es dir schwer alter sehr stört ja
wir sind auf jeden fall ein blogger okay
aber uns ist niemand nach gesetzen der
block um da oben sind ganz böse nicht
mehr ja ich sehe gerade einen reisen so
so ein arsch voll citrin also
entschuldigt die wortwahl aber ich habe
vor allem ein wenig an der kg essen ich
brauche dringend irgendwelche ich habe
noch eineinhalb album arbeiten als krieg
schaden dann kommen wir kaum ruhig
entgegen
ja ich habe ein bisschen also vielleicht
sechs sieben gebrannt das fleisch oder
es perfekt dann kann ich vielleicht
einmal kommt der krieg schon okay ich
gebe einfach den gang runter ne ich
komme zu die hoch dass das tier etwas
hier hast du das nicht hast du das ein
mann kann ich mit strg treffen
nee das geht nicht warum das denn
keine ahnung das ist irgendwie immer so
das war auch bei legend somit man kann
nicht mit s t ag alles aufstocken
wahrscheinlich damit man das schwert
nicht klappen könnte aber ein bisschen
behindert finde ich wir haben unser
eisen jung und jetzt wird die tri gefahr
wenn die erste farbe wieso ist denn
niemand dieser eine dia ich meine letzte
folge gesehen zu haben dass ihr and diaz
war hatte vielleicht hast du dich hier
runter gebaut - order gebaut seiten also
entweder wir waren das oder jemand hat
sich umgeschaut aber dann will ich mich
sehr wundern warum er denn neben ihn
nicht dass sondern warum er abgebaut
ja ok aber es ist ja auch noch alles so
wie dies zu gebaut hatten oder der trick
ist um dieses zitat aus den blöcken zu
kräften das übrigens gold braucht man
nicht den üblichen stick sondern das hab
ich noch mal nachgeschaut man braucht
einen smart handel und das besteht aus
zwei reisen also wo man zuerst einmal
nice citrin ist angefahren werden
die ihr eingesammelt läuft bei uns
bisschen legen welche auf dem tsv das
kein ding du bei mir panik finde ich das
ein wenig vielleicht einfach nur am
abspeisen
okay vielleicht kann ich dir doppel dann
versucht so wenig wie möglich zu
sprengen auch beim verbrauch man eh voll
wenig energie ja wir gehen dann einfach
jetzt runter in diese fette halle wo das
noch ein bisschen mehr photonen wovon zu
einem rausfahren ausfüllen so
aufgenommen es ist halt draußen nach das
nicht sogar die rüstung was braucht man
dafür lassen ein bisschen was in den
ofen ballern
das geht aber nicht in offen
wir müssen wir noch mal informieren wir
fahren aber vielleicht gibt es sowas
aber offen gibt dann wird er das
wahrscheinlich dafür aber ist das so
sehe ich bin ja wir haben es einfach
pech gehabt
okay ich gehe mal runter in diese halle
die ich mir gemacht in diesem in
strippen eingang gut mitgemacht habt
leistet haben wie es bisschen
orientierungslos aber ich nehme noch
bisschen witzig sondern schwein wollen
diese halle sind halt irgendwie todes
liefen
einerseits und andererseits aber so
normale oft auch irgendwie wenig auf
deshalb gehe ich lieber in den strippen
eingang als darunter schon zu wenig aber
ich habe auf jeden fall schon 32 von
diesem grünen rolf eden und wir waren
noch nie und nimmer zwei schweinefleisch
ein wie viele von den 32 von den citrin
ja da hast du alles abgeräumt was da
oben ist sowas oben ist habe ich
abgebaut und unten in der höhle ist ja
noch mehr und jetzt habe ich auch hier
von der iren ein kleines alter ich bin
so froh dass ich fast food ein junge
das war das größte problem bei legend
weil es mir wohl dass wir einfach keine
guten zeiten habe ich hier gut von daher
darauf wir können uns gleich ein schwert
daraus machen auszeichnet hat mehr tag
der mensch als statisten schwert ja wohl
mal machen wir auch machen
also ich hab ich habe fünf da kann man
einen bau- und ein schwert man
vielleicht okay ich hab jetzt ein
bisschen food geholt kommen jetzt mal
rein in die hört wieder ich glaube ich
hätte ausrasten sollen als sicherheiten
zurückgefunden ich glaube dass ist gut
gerade du kannst einfach jetzt ausrasten
beschäftigt großen höhlen eingang also
scheinbar haben wir etwas gutes gefunden
leute die wendung also das glück bei uns
holt diese wendung hatten wir uns echt
verdient nach diesem ersten sehr sehr
suboptimalen start und ich komm runter
dann fühlen wir uns morgen im land
zusammen
das ganze machen ich habe diese annimmt
ich bin der neiße horn höhle ist der
kohle kohle ist hier auch sogar eine
menge lauf einfach mal diesen gar nicht
gebaut habe alles was ich habe jetzt
fünf schweine hasen tomb raider hitman
aber ich glaube es ist richtig weil ich
halt keine fakten
ich habe erst mal wieder ich habe 22
aber lasst uns mal hast du überhaupt
holz dabei sieben teams der usa reisen
hast du ein crafting table mit noch mehr
seiten ja noch ein junger alter okay ich
werd incoming dass ich mal kurz decken
brauchen machte fackeln hier also alles
auf kraft und pilzen und da gucken mal
kurz an diesem kalten schwerter glaube
dass dieses orchester op ist dass wir
gerade die ganze zeit finden und ich
habe jetzt schon über 10 von alten sword
2 2 endet und dort handle
ihm geht mir macht man denn ingrid aus
dem wallis nachschauen in dem alles okay
dann brauchen wir den unbedingten willen
sollte mir vielleicht diese diese folge
noch machen ich habe nochmal drei alben
die brennbaren gebe künstlich den fall
dass machen
ich habe auch noch eine ganze menge
allen frage ist das verbrennen wir jetzt
hier
dann mag ich jetzt mal war einmal ein
fernes machen wir erstmal ja ich habe
mich leider ist hier 10
dann mache ich immer zum brennen aber du
kannst mal schauen was es für ein in
gebrauch von diesem
citrin einfach einmal rennen hatte ja
einfach in den bus und brennen händlern
ist das ja viel zu viel wasser in der
höhle ist es braucht mir nicht mal zwölf
minuten die wand hatte einst die
training geht ist einfach ein ohr
gebrannt
zumindest mal eine vorrichtung zwei
schwerter machen wir sind wir früher
eben also wir voll citrin halten
schwerter alle disziplinen
ja man glaube ich einfach nur echt eine
menge pech am anfang mit links
mathematik sondern der scheiße es misst
111 minuten 13 minuten das läuft auf
jeden fall dann sind wir gleich bei der
ist dann kommt vielleicht noch mal
runter oder visa haben jetzt die große
höhle gar nicht geholt
wir nehmen das ja das ganze citrin drin
und ich habe jetzt schon 750 dann lasst
uns doch erstmal die zieht in die höhe
über steffen und dass die sache in der
mitten im oder wir sind ja sie bei 13 42
dass wir unten vielleicht in der höhle
die nächste folge anfang okay wir können
auf jeden fall genug material für den
anwalt johannes kann man uns holen dann
hattest du dass das fleisch mitgenommen
habe ich mich so dann ab jetzt vor allem
zwölf titel das heißt für uns weil
schwert bogen richtig op müssen wir
schauen dass sie überlegen ob man
vielleicht sogar einen titel citrin zwar
noch die zwei auf die eins machen dann
hier bestimmt nicht geben citrin
abreisen chance hat 95 prozent
laut nicht unsere tipps und das nicht
machen was ich manchmal blogs oder foren
dinger da vorne ist irgend so ein fitter
brunnen in der mitte wo bis wo wir uns
hier runter junge weiß darunter gehalten
in der mitte ist am boden lassen
probieren noch aus checken glaube da ist
die wahre und enes hinter dieser
schlucht offen ist ob jene profis
das aber ist nicht nicht nicht übereilen
die noch über flippern ist da was drin
sind es denn für alles ist drin
die brennen wie können die berechnung
das was drin dass man was brennen lassen
hat so ok ab lasst mal probieren dieses
ding in der mitte aus zu checken
ich kann schon nicht mehr springen das
fleisch da oben wollen wir hier schnell
aufstand sind das wächter zombies oder
stehe ist das rennen das er da so cool
steht
okay das sind das eine tun ohne das
junge dass der truhe junge da ist eine
truhe und das ist die tour innerhalb des
kicker teils von daher machen wir haben
die tore der nächsten folge nächste
folge allerdings in einer minute gekickt
wir haben haben noch eine menge zeit
aber nein wir machen nicht dieses wir
öfters nicht wenigstens das nicht in der
nächsten folge aufmachen oder wir
schauen gleichzeitig an nun ist es halt
der falle
vielleicht aber gibt's nicht fallen aber
dann geh du auf jeden fall mal 30 blöcke
weg ist kein scheiß
oder glaubst du vielleicht können wir
das irgendwie wir können das aus sie
guckt euch das an leute das gibt's doch
nicht also ich das jetzt auch machen
oder den nächsten fall ich weiß es nicht
geh weg stellen
man sieht was ist los mit euch man dann
ernst und wir wollen die kick-back alte
radler jemand davor dran oder ist
vielleicht der eigentliche schatz
darunter das loch control alt dann hat
er uns verarschen oder der eiger der
eigentliche schatz ist nicht darunter
wir schauen auf jeden fall in der
nächsten folge nach wollte
die gefallen hat haut rein macht uns